I will have the grab a goal
what
the Gabba ghoul
I don't really know what that is
I don't I don't I don't have to have
this trying to say is
attention everyone may I have your
attention there are four new deadly
weapons in this office
Basher Thrasher Crasher and Smasher
Smasher know where'd you get that
fireball cat
this morning after hours of combat with
some of the city's best teenagers I
earned my black belt in gojoku martial
arts
I had to find a new Dojo after Sensei
IRA and I parted ways my new Sensei
Sensei Billy thought I had more than
enough training to take the test turns
out Sensei Ira was a bit of a shyster
Sensei Billy says most students don't
spend 150 000 over 20 years to get their
black belt
hi hi I will now perform the ceremonial
changing of the belt he will now perform
the ceremonial changing of
it's not a large group
take my belt my beluster I now submit to
you every part of myself that's really
okay I'm mostly focused on the Belt here
just slip it off my slip it off my hips
take a step back take a step back
okay okay I can't do this if you're
going to be thrusting like that okay
I think I'm gonna have to cut this off
he will now perform the ceremonial
cutting off of the belt
Dwight has been practicing karate for
years
when we were dating I would help him
with his strength training
he would strap me to his chest in a Baby
Bjorn made for fat children
and do lunges across the farm
I felt like I was flying
there it is
we did it he did it
I love you
all right I will now perform
my final Kata forms you're gonna watch
me right yes okay
Sensei you're not watching yep I'm
watching just do it
God
yeah God
oh
watching I'm watching
watch this part okay
sensei do you generally do what else
calls like this like you could just call
me Billy and no no but Dwight insisted
he wanted to receive his black belt in
the place he loves most in the world you
see that oh
he's an odd guy isn't he yes
irritating also yes but I gotta hand it
to him he's one of the most tenacious
and determined man I've ever met oh
you successfully backed down the mob you
made the mafia apologize to you you made
the mafia be polite
oh man